- [Elizabeth] The government
proposed and we agree
that you should spend a term
at the University there,
to learn the language.
- But--
- No buts.
- But I'm really rather
happy at Cambridge,
not to mention I've just been
cast in a wonderful role.
- [Elizabeth] I know, but--
- I thought no buts.
(gentle upbeat music)
- The investiture of Prince
Charles in 1969 was far more
than just a ceremony.
It was a culmination of a
carefully planned strategy
to propel him into the
affections of the public.
And, as we'll find out,
there's a lot more to it
than meets the eye.
I'm Laura Jackson and this
is "Beneath the Crown."
(upbeat music)
The world nowadays is used to seeing
and hearing Prince Charles,
the Prince of Wales.
It was a different story prior
to his investiture in July 1969.
As a 20-year-old heir to the throne
had been a largely unknown quantity
in the eyes of the public.
But then it dawned on
the struggling monarchy
and government, maybe this
shy, young man could be used
as a powerful PR tool for them both.
(upbeat music)
The royal family were being left behind
by a cultural revolution that put youth
and modernity center stage
in the Swinging Sixties.
(upbeat music)
The Labor government was
also in trouble as the rise
of Nationalism in Wales
risked eroding their support.
With the Welsh National
Party, Plaid Cymru,
having its first MP, Gwynfor
Evans, elected in 1966.
- I therefore declare Gwynfor
Richard Evans duly elected.
- -[Announcer] Mr. Gwynfor
Evans said that no English party
can now regard a seat
in Wales as being safe.
- A plan was hatched to
introduce Prince Charles
as the Prince of Wales,
despite him taking on the
role over a decade earlier.
Charles would win over the
masses, prove his Welshness,
and cement his position
as the Prince of Wales,
through a televised
coronation-like ceremony
known as an investiture.
- Good, that's settled then.
(upbeat music)
- [Laura] But first,
there was the small matter
of whisking him off to
Wales to learn the language.
- (speaking foreign language)
Welcome to Wales.
(upbeat music)
- [Laura] In April, 1969,
Prince Charles enrolled
for one term at the University
of Wales in Aberystwyth.
(upbeat music)
There, he studied Welsh
culture, history, and language,
ahead of the investiture
date of July the first.
(upbeat music)
Time was running out to
master the native tongue.
(upbeat music)
- (speaking foreign language)
(groaning)
Glide into the ooh.
- I'm trying to glide into ow.
- Fine.
- Security fears due
to the growing Welsh
Nationalist Movement's use
of aggressive and violent methods
led to 70 police officers being placed in
and around the University.
Some were even deployed to work undercover
as cleaners and students.
Everything seemed to be
going surprisingly smoothly.
(upbeat music)
(clapping)
Until Prince Charles was about
to give his first major public
speech in Welsh in late May.
(booing)
A large group of protestors
rose from their seats
to heckle him when he arrived on stage.
The young Prince cut a lonely figure.
But the protestors were soon driven out
by the unlikely combination of police
and elderly ladies
wielding their handbags.
Charles' dignified
response drew appreciation
from the audience and calmed his nerves.
(clapping)
(cheering)
The speech itself went down a treat.
- (speaking foreign language)
(clapping)
(cheering)
- With one month to go
until his investiture,
a media blitz kicked in
as Prince Charles was
interviewed several times
across British TV and radio.
It was an attempt to
launch him into the hearts
and minds of the British public,
as the leader of the
next generation of royals
and heir to the throne.
- It's a dual sort of upbringing
one has to try and do.
And I think perhaps
that I'd gone to school,
at University and everything,
in a much more normal way
than any of my predecessors did,
has been an experiment in royal education.
And of course, it has
been slightly difficult.
- He came across as a
more modern, sensitive,
and relatable royal than
people were used to.
He was also able to
convey his love for Wales.
- When I first arrived,
I wanted to get out,
you know, as much as possible.
So I went and went for drives
through the countryside
and walked in the mountains,
exhausted my poor policeman,
walking up and down the mountain.
And I've seen a lot and
I've been very touched
by the way people have,
you know, responded,
the country people particularly.
- While his relaxed manner
and humor disarmed many,
the government was concerned
that Prince Charles may be
growing a little too sympathetic
to the Welsh Nationalist cause.
- I think the fatal
attitude to take is to say
that these people are wrong, you know.
Therefore, you know, they
mustn't be listed to or heeded.
But I think what one must
try and do is, first of all,
establish a personal
contact and actually speak
to the people and understand
what it is they're trying to get at.
And a basic sympathy, I think,
is needed, an understanding.
(gentle upbeat music)
- Preparations for the
investiture ceremony
at Caernarfon Castle had been
causing plenty of headaches
inside Buckingham Palace.
Several senior members of staff
preferred a traditional approach.
But Lord Snowdon, Antony Armstrong-Jones,
had been brought on board
to modernize proceedings,
including the clothing and stage design.
- This looks super.
I must say, an absolute plain slate.
For the important thing about this is so
that cameras can come in from
behind and from in front.
(exciting music)
- [Announcer] At this carved Welsh slate,
impressive in its simplicity,
this was the stage where Wales
would receive its own Prince.
(gentle upbeat music)
- As the big day approached,
security concerns grew.
There had been numerous
bomb attempts designed
to cause chaos.
But the night before the investiture,
a bomb carried by two
activists exploded prematurely,
killing them both.
During an enormous security
and surveillance operation,
Prince Charles' investiture
went ahead as planned.
(cheering)
And the crowds were out in force.
(gentle upbeat music)
The ceremony was faultless,
with the Queen investing her son
with the symbols of his office.
- [Announcer] A coronet for sovereignty.
(gentle upbeat music)
- [Laura] The crown
designed by Louis Osman
was controversial at the
time for its modern look.
(gentle upbeat music)
It's been widely claimed
that the orb at the top was,
in fact, a gold-plated table tennis ball.
(gentle upbeat music)
- I hope and trust that, in time,
I shall be able to offer
my own contribution.
And to do that, I seek your
cooperation and understanding.
(gentle upbeat music)
Speaking for myself, as a
result of my two months stay
in this country, I have
come to see far more
in the title I hold than hitherto.
I am more than grateful to the
people of this principality
for making my brief stay
so immensely worthwhile.
And for giving me such encouragement
in the learning of the language.
- The reception to the ceremony
and Prince Charles' speech was rapturous.
(gentle upbeat music)
A global audience of 500 million people,
including 19 million from the
UK, watched on television.
(gentle upbeat music)
But while the investiture
itself was a success,
the question remained.
Was Prince Charles really cut
out for the prominent role
the royal family needed him to play?
(gentle upbeat music)
- I have a beating heart, a character,
a mind and a will of my own.
I am not just a symbol.
I can lead not just by wearing a uniform
or by cutting a ribbon, but
by showing people who I am.
(whooshing)